NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY MERRY
CHRISTMAS FROM THE SHUT-INS.
NOW GUYS, I DID NOT WANT TO
DO THIS ALONE SO HERE THOP
US WITH YOU ARE NEXT GAME
FROM THE MOVIE THE INTERVIEW,
SETH ROGAN AND JAMES
FRANCO!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
WELCOME, WELCOME. MR. FRANCO,
WELCOME, WELCOME.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR DROPPING BY,
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> YEAH, OUR PLEASURE, CHRIS.
'TIS THE SEASON.
>> CHRIS: YES, FOR PROMOTING
MOVIES.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, WHATEVER.
>> SURE. SPEAKING OF OUR MOVIE
THE INTERVIEW, IT COMES OUT
CHRISTMAS DAY, EVERYBODY.
>> CHRIS: NICE, NICE. THAT'S A
NICE TO THING TO DO.
YEAH.
>> AND WHAT A PERFECT
COINCIDENCE, GUYS THIS JUST
HAPPENS TO BE WHAT OUR NEXT
GAME IS ALL ABOUT.
CHRISTMAS.
>> YAY! THAT IS AMAZING HOW
THAT WORKED OUT.
I'M VERY EXCITED.
>> IT IS LIKE IT'S FATE.
>> CHRIS: IT'S FATED. IT'S FATED
THAT YOU WERE HERE, THAT YOU
MADE A MOVIE AND IT'S GOING TO
COME ON OUT ON CHRISTMAS,
AND IT'S CHRISTMASTIME.
I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T KNOW.
SO THERE THIS GAME ARE YOU
GOING TO BE SHOWING US
PEOPLE AWKWARD FAMILY
CHRISTMAS PHOTOS AND THE
COMICS HAVE TO GIVE A LINE
IN THE CHRISTMAS CARD.
DOES THAT ABOUT SUM IT UP?
>> THAT SOUNDS EXACTLY
CORRECT.
AND WE FIGURED A GOOD WAY TO
START THAT GAME WAS TO SHOW MINE
AND FRANCO'S CHRISTMAS CARD THAT
WE MADE.
>> CHRIS: OH, THAT'S SO NICE.
LET'S SEE IT. LET'S SEE IT.
FANTASTIC.
SO NICE.
>> IT IS NICE.
>> CHRIS: WHAT WOULD BE A LINE
FOR THIS CHRISTMAS CARD.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
WHOEVER WE HIRED TO PLAY
THAT SANTA CLAUS WAS NOT
NEARLY AS BUMMED OUT ABOUT
THIS PICTURE AS HE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN.
>> SO SETH AND JAMES ARE
GOING TO STICK AROUND BUT
LET'S LOOK AT MORE WEIRDO
CHRISTMAS PHOTOS.
FIRST UP THIS HUMAN
SANTA-PEDE.
>> OH.
>> THE RUDOLPH IN THIS
SCENARIO DOES NOT LOOK VERY
HAPPY.
JUDAH, YOU LOOK SUPERBUMMED
OUT BY THIS.
>> I WOULD SAY LAST ONE BUTT
[BLEEP] SAY ROTTEN EGG.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. POINTS.
>> GREAT JOB.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR
HIM SAY ALL RIGHT, LOWER THE
ANTLERS, EVERYBODY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> CHRIS: DOES THIS MEAN
ANYTHING TO YOU, FRANCO?
>> I GOT NOTHING.
>> FRANCO WAS ACTUALLY PHOTO
SHOPPED OUT OF THIS PHOTO.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, THESE
GHOSTS OF BOY BAND PAST.
>> CHRIS: SNOW-OH OH OH.
JUDAH.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
ALMOST A YEAR SINCE OUR
SNOWMAN KILLED HIMSELF.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, OKAY, POINTS.
100 POINTS FOR THAT ONE.
>> I WANT TO COMMENT ON THE
SCOPE OF THIS [BLEEP]
SNOWMAN.
>> THAT IS THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE.
>> WE CAN MOCK THESE GUYS
ALL WE WANT, THAT'S IS THE
BEST SNOWMAN I HAVE SEEN IN
MY ENTIRE [BLEEP] LIFE.
>> CHRIS: NO, YOU'RE RIGHT,
YOU'RE RIGHT, THESE GUYS GOT IT
DONE.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE, THE
CHRISTMAS MORNING LIBERATION
FRONT.
WHAT?
KIDS CAN'T HAVE ASSAULT
RIFLES ANY MORE? JUDAH.
>> I CONDITION BELIEVE IT'S
BEEN ALMOST A YEAR SINCE WE
KILLED SANTA CLAUS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. SURE.
>> I'M JUST GENUINELY
THINKING WHAT THE LEAST
JEWISH THING ABOUT THIS
PICTURE IS.
IT'S THE CHRISTMAS, THE
BLOND HAIR OR ITS GUNS.
I REALLY CAN'T TELL.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT.
LAST ONE, THIS NONTRADITIONAL
FAMILY, IS A VERY --
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> CHRIS: YES, BROOKS.
>> THINGS AREN'T GOING GREAT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> FOR ANY OF US.
ALL THREE OF US, THIS IS A
LOW POINT.
>> YEAH --
>> CHRIS: JUDAH.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE I HAVEN'T
KILLED MYSELF YET.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS.
HAPPY HANUKKAH.
>> MR. FRANCO DO YOU HAVE A
COMMENT FOR THIS?
OR ARE YOU --
>> I THINK HE'S MAKING THE BEST
OF IT.
>> CHRIS: HE IS. WE'RE
[BLEEP]ING ON THIS GUY --
>> FRANCO, POINT.
>> CHRIS: THAT EAT END OF MERRY
CHRISTMAS FOR THE SHUT-INS.
WATCH THE INTERVIEW,
CHRISTMAS DAY, SETH
REGULAREN AND JAMES FRANCO,
EVERYBODY.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, THANK YOU,
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AND THERE THEY GO!